for the first time on television 48
hours is revealing letters written by
the so-called dexter killer police say
mark twitchell was fascinated with the
fictional serial killer on the popular
tv series dexter twitchell himself was
convicted in 2011 and while in prison he
wrote dozens of detailed letters to an
investigative journalist
48 hours contributor troy roberts spoke
with that reporter and got a look at
those letters
mark twitchell was an aspiring filmmaker
husband and father when in 2008 he posed
as a woman on a dating website and lord
johnny altinger a random stranger to a
garage where he killed him
he was just a typical local guy who had
dreams of making it big in hollywood
action and really no red flags no
warning signs that something like this
was on the horizon
steve lillibun is an investigative
journalist and an author lil buen was
stunned when he heard from mark
twitchell as he began working on a book
about the case he wrote me probably 350
pages of letters
the fact is society in general has a
deep and profound fascination with the
dark side of human nature twitchell's
fascination with the dark side seemed to
focus around the character dexter morgan
from the showtime series mark twitchell
wrote to me quite extensively about his
interest in dexter nobody would side
with dexter morgan if you went around
slaughtering school teachers and mail
carriers on a whim
there's significant links to dexter
twitchell had a kill room set up with
plastic sheeting he had a table set up
for his victims he had
this kind of processing kit that was
very similar to what dexter uses
he's a depraved individual and he knows
that retired fbi criminal profiler julia
kelly reviewed mark twitchell's writings
for 48 hours
she thinks she knows what made twitchell
tick
i think he identified with dexter to
some degree i think he's different than
dexter he's not killing bad guys he's
killing very innocent good people living
productive lives
cali believes twitchell took pleasure in
planning and executing his crimes as if
they were romantic trysts
he's
targeting men that perhaps he would be
interested in having a date with
it's a combination of a sexual motive
and a thrill killing
in 2023 twitchell will be eligible to
apply for early parole
experts say it's a long shot mark
twitchell cannot be rehabilitated this
is who he is
and troy roberts is with us troy good
morning wow this really is a look inside
the mind of a killer 350 letters and
twitchell might be paroled is that true
well uh he's going to apply um stranger
things have happened i can't imagine
that they would grant him parole he
hasn't expressed any remorse
for what he has done
[Music]
you know what was so remarkable about
about this story is that he's
unremarkable
an average guy
he's kind of decent looking affable
intelligent he's a
a husband a father and
a guy you would chat to at a bar
not knowing he harbors these sick
fantasies so you know looks can be
deceiving you didn't meet him but the
investigative reporter you spoke with
did what was her what was her impression
that his impression was what i just
just said i mean normal manipulative
uh charming guy
um trying to win you over um
uh but no hint of the dark side and
that's scary
because you know you don't you know
he's not frothing at the mouth his eyes
aren't spinning in his head right but
and uh but he was able to do just so
much harm there's no signs
no signal oh boy those images is the
kill room with the
trash bags haunting stuff uh troy thank
you very much can't wait to watch
you can see troy's report the dexter
killer on 48 hours tomorrow night at 10
9 central right here on cbs and on our
streaming service paramount plus